ya he hecho un montón de vídeos que
cubren lo que voy a abordar en este
vídeo y la razón por la que estoy
haciendo esto es porque tengo la
necesidad de repasar yo mismo porque el
descuento que estaba haciendo algunos
problemas de cálculo que requerían que
supiera esto y ahora que ya tenemos un
buen software para grabar pues así
matamos dos pájaros de un tiro' yo yo
grabó un vídeo nuevo de identidades
trigonométricas y al mismo tiempo
podemos repasar juntos qué es lo que lo
que nos dicen estas identidades así que
tenemos que partir de algunas
identidades que ya he demostrado y que
no lo voy a hacer aquí porque sería muy
complicado pero pueden repasar los
vídeos y voy a partir de ésta
principalmente que es el seno de hamás b
ok esto es igual al seno de a nos
tomamos el primero y luego lo
multiplicamos por el coseno del segundo
y luego sumamos el seno del segundo seno
debe por el coseno
primero muy bien esta es la identidad de
la cual vamos a partir y con esta
inmediatamente podemos deducir la
siguiente qué pasa si yo quiero calcular
el seno de a más menos un ángulo menos
sé digamos ok esto es lo mismo que a
menos es verdad entonces simplemente si
sustituimos en esta fórmula de acá
arriba que es lo que nos da a ver
tendremos seno de a seno de a por el
coseno de menos de menos más el seno de
menos c por el cose no vea muy bien
entonces ahora hay que recordar otra
cosa hay que recordar otra cosa y es que
el coseno el co seno de menos sé quién
es pues simplemente es coseno desee para
el coseno no le importan los signos
simplemente se los come muy bien y esto
es justamente la propiedad de que el
coche no sea una función par que no le
no le pase nada con los signos
por otro lado tendremos
la propiedad que es el de seno de menos
c es igual a aquí lo que va a pasar con
él con el signo menos es que sale del
pse no va a ser menos seno de sé muy
bien y esta es la propiedad de que la
función se no sea una función impar muy
bien entonces si utilizamos esto en
nuestra formulita de acá arriba que es
lo que nos queda nos queda que esto será
igual al seno de a se queda igual seno
de a por el coseno de menos que es el
coche no desee muy bien y ahora tenemos
aquí seno de menos esto es menos seno de
se por el coseno idea muy bien y esto es
el seno de a menos verdad oa más menos
es lo mismo es la resta eso es lo
importante
ok entonces otra otra fórmula que
tenemos que tener muy en mente es es la
siguiente que el cose no la suma el
coseno de una suma de ángulos
se nos ve esto aquí lo que va a pasar
con el coche no es que no se mezclan
senos con cosenos simplemente tendremos
coseno de a por el coche no debe y aquí
va un menos menos seno de a
se no debe muy bien esta fórmula también
ya la hemos visto en otros vídeos así
que vamos a darla por hecho y con esto
podemos deducir cuál es el coste no de a
menos b verdad porque si sustituimos que
es lo que vamos a tener coseno de a
por el coseno de - b pero dijimos que no
le hace nada el signo verdad entonces
simplemente nos queda jose no debe ahora
aquí vamos a tener seno de a por el seno
de menos b pero el seno de menos b es
menos el seno de b que con este menos de
aquí se cancela y entonces nos queda más
seno de a
se no debe muy bien entonces hasta aquí
vamos muy bien y estas son las
identidades de las cuales voy a partir
muy bien vamos a ver qué vamos a tener
fíjense que con esto vamos a obtener
muchísimas identidades vamos a ver qué
pasaría si yo quiero ser saber o
calcular cuál es el co seno de un doble
ángulo o de dos veces a muy bien esto
por pues simplemente porque dos veces a
es lo siguiente a más a verdad entonces
yo puedo utilizar el co seno de una suma
para calcular coseno de a más
entonces esto es coseno de a por el
coseno de la segunda que es coseno de a
menos seno de a seno de a por el seno de
la segunda que esencialmente no es que
sea la segunda es la misma verdad
entonces esto que es lo que nos queda
esto nos queda simplemente coseno dea
por coseno de a es coseno cuadrado de a
y seno de a por seno de a es seno
cuadrado de así
hay que restar seno cuadrado de a muy
bien entonces una fórmula para el coseno
del doble ángulo es las siguientes
coseno de 2 aesco seno cuadrado menos
seno cuadrado y ahora voy a empezar
enmarcar todas las identidades que vamos
obteniendo en este vídeo esta es la
primera que obtuvimos coseno de 2 a
escocia no cuadrado menos seno cuadrado
muy bien y ahora qué pasaría si por
ejemplo yo quiero que el coseno del
doble ángulo quede solo en términos del
coseno ok aquí tenemos un seno que tal
que yo quiero que sólo quede en términos
de coseno bueno pues para esto hay que
recordar que las funciones
trigonométricas vienen de nuestro
círculo unitario verdad cumplen la
identidad básica y fundamental de la de
la trigonometría que es esto el seno
cuadrado más el coseno cuadrado es igual
a 1 muy bien entonces cómo podemos saber
aquí tenemos un seno cuadrado entonces
aquí podemos despejar seno cuadrado por
ejemplo si restamos
coseno cuadrado de ambos lados tendremos
seno cuadrado de a igual a 1 - el coseno
cuadrado de a muy bien entonces esto de
aquí lo podemos sustituir en esta parte
de acá arriba y que es lo que nos queda
nos queda igual al coseno cuadrado de a
menos y aquí es en donde sustituimos
seno cuadrado que es uno menos coseno
cuadrado de perdón así menos coseno
cuadrado de ahí estamos bien muy bien y
esto que va a ser igual bueno aquí
tenemos este coseno cuadrado de a menos
uno y aquí tenemos menos menos coseno
cuadrado de a que es más coseno cuadrado
de a y esto al sumarlo simplemente
fíjense que aquí tenemos un coseno
cuadrado y otro coseno cuadrado y luego
le restamos uno entonces nos queda dos
veces el coseno cuadrado de a menos
ok y con esto ya podemos concluir que
esta es otra forma de escribir el coseno
de 2a muy bien y este también lo voy a
enmarcar porque ya es otra identidad que
obtuvimos ahí está
entonces ahora piensen en lo siguiente
qué pasa si yo quiero hallar quién es el
coseno cuadrado de a ok quién sería el
coseno cuadrado de a bueno con esta
identidad que acabo de enmarcar
yo puedo calcular quién es el coseno
cuadrado de a vamos a ver cómo es eso
voy a bajar un poco y tenemos dos veces
por ejemplo si de aquí sumamos uno de
ambos lados
tendremos dos coseno cuadrado de a es
igual a coseno de dos a más uno verdad y
ahora si dividimos de ambos lados entre
dos tendremos coseno cuadrado de a es
igual a un medio por el coseno de dos a
más uno muy bien y así es otra forma de
ver el coseno cuadrado de a muy bien ahí
lo tienen
este es el coseno cuadrado de ahí esta
identidad a veces se le conoce como la
identidad de reducción de potencia y
fíjense que es porque aquí tenemos una
potencia de 2
aparece con potencia 1 aunque aparece
con un 2 en el argumento del coseno
verdad en donde estamos evaluando el
coseno muy bien ahora ya tenemos una
fórmula para coseno cuadrado kit qué tal
si queremos encontrar una fórmula para
el seno cuadrado bueno de aquí de esta
de acá arriba ahora en vez de despejar
el seno cuadrado despejamos el coseno
cuadrado y que es lo que tenemos coseno
cuadrado de a es igual a restamos seno
cuadrado de ambos lados y nos queda uno
menos seno cuadrado de a muy bien
entonces con esto podrían 1 por ejemplo
tomar este esta fórmula de aquí esta
fórmula que tenemos en rosa déjenme
ponerla y en vez de poner coseno
cuadrado vamos a poner este 1 - seno
cuadrado muy bien entonces tenemos
coseno de 2a es igual a en vez de este
coseno cuadrado pongo uno menos seno
cuadrado de a
muy bien - seno cuadrado de a ok
entonces quien es esto
esto es igual a 1 - aquí tengo menos
seno cuadrado de a y restó otro seno
cuadrado de a ahí tenemos menos 2 seno
cuadrado de ahí y esto es el coseno de 2
entonces si de aquí despejó seno
cuadrado ya podremos obtener la
identidad que estábamos buscando vamos a
ver esto lo podemos hacer de la
siguiente de hecho este este lo pueden
marcar verdad es otra identidad para
escribir el coseno de 2 a si se dan
cuenta ya tenemos muchas identidades
para el coseno de 2 a pero bueno ahora
vamos a ver tenemos que despejar de aquí
seno cuadrado por ejemplo si restamos de
ambos lados 2 seno cuadrado de a
tendremos en más bien si sumamos verdad
si sumamos de ambos lados sumamos de
ambos lados 12 no cuadrado de a más
coseno de 2a es igual a 1
ahora restamos de ambos lados coseno de
2a y nos queda 2 seno cuadrado de a le
restamos este y nos queda uno menos
coseno de 2a y ahora dividimos entre dos
de ambos lados y nos queda seno cuadrado
de a es igual a un medio de uno menos
coseno de 2a
muy bien y aquí ya tenemos esta fórmula
para el seno cuadrado de un ángulo o de
un número muy bien y fíjense bien en la
asimetría que hay entre el seno cuadrado
y el coseno cuadrado aquí en realidad el
seno cuadrado y el cocinó cuadrado son
exactamente iguales excepto que cambian
el signo verdad simplemente tienen un
signo contrario pero bueno eso eso era
lo bonito que quería que observáramos
vamos a seguir buscando cosas
interesantes por ejemplo ya tenemos el
coseno de dos veces un número que tal el
seno
seno de 2a por ejemplo y esto será igual
al seno de a más
y hay que recordar la fórmula que
tenemos para el seno de una suma que es
seno del primero coseno del segundo más
seno del segundo coseno del primero
entonces esto es seno del primero que es
a por coseno del segundo que también
está más seno del segundo que es a por
coseno del primero entonces
esencialmente si se dan cuenta
cada uno de estos sumandos es igual y
esto es igual esto es igual a dos veces
seno de a por él coseno dea y esto es el
seno de dos y muy bien en esta también
la vamos a enmarcar porque es una
fórmula que hemos obtenido y si se dan
cuenta todo esto lo obtuvimos de
identidades muy sencillas está por
ejemplo estas de aquí y el coseno de una
suma a las otras incluso hasta pudimos
deducir las entonces creo que ya fueron
suficientes identidad y perdón
identidades o al menos yo necesito ya un
buen descanso por suerte repasamos las
identidades que necesitaba así que
espero que que haya sido un buen repaso
para ti también por supuesto puedes
escribirlas o memorizar las pero lo más
importante de todo esto es que puedas
deducir las a partir de las
entidades con las que con las que
empezamos más bien
al inicio del vídeo nos vemos pronto